uplifted eight time i could really use
an uplift this morning we're gonna share
the stories that bring you some joy to
your day and what better delivery
mechanism than vlad duties what do you
got vlad so this is gonna bring the
crick the crick the cricket right out of
your net brother it's gonna really
loosen you up because i got a really
really sweet story today it happened at
a recent lunch for tony award nominees
at the prestigious rainbow room in
rockefeller plaza one of the actresses
being honored her name is carrie young
she's nominated for her broadway debut
in clyde's so when it came time to call
her name the announcer also acknowledged
someone else her father who was working
at the event as a server
yes his name is mr clay young and he's
been working at the rainbow room for
more than 30 years to support his family
serving everyone from former presidents
to celebrities clay emigrated from
belize and he's been working in
hospitality since 1975 and when his name
was mentioned the room burst into
applause and everyone gave him a
standing ovation there wasn't a dry eye
in sight watch this
when
has a server ever been acknowledged in
this room in that way and that was just
so like profound to me
you know and i said i was like i'm happy
i was there for that moment
from what i came from when they stood up
and
acknowledged
my daughter's work
and acknowledged me
in the same breath
was beyond touching for me
clay told us that he always knew his
daughter would be successful and cara is
taking her dad as her plus one to the
tony awards on sunday you guys isn't
that adorable
so part of what makes it so sweet is
that uh that nominees luncheon uh you
can't have a plus one you can't bring
your sister you can't bring your parents
so he happened to be working there which
also allowed him to be the only parent
in the room that's incredible anything
for anything you know i also did a story
a couple of years ago for cbs morning's
on an author tiffany jackson whose
father has been a times square vendor
for her entire life and you think to
yourself time square vendor but he put
his daughter to school
on that job on that salary she knows
times square better than anyone on the
street she knows all the great doormen
all the great places to go to the
bathroom and she's a celebrated author
now yeah i just love stories i serve my
daughter lunch
you sleep on the floor with teddy